– Also, welche Informationen
gehören in den Lebenslauf?
– Name und Adresse?
– Sehr gut. Was noch?
– Wo ich gelernt habe?
– Ja genau, die Schulbildung.
Wart ihr in Deutschland auf einem
Gymnasium oder einer Realschule?
Oder wie hieß die Schule
in eurem Heimatland?
Dazu gehört auch der Schulabschluss.
Habt ihr Abitur oder einen anderen
Abschluss? Schreibt es auf.
– Könnten Praktikums wichtig sein?
– Die Mehrzahl von „Praktikum“ ist „Praktika“.
Das ist ein lateinisches Wort.
Aber ja, Praktika sind auch wichtig.
Dazu gehört auch Berufserfahrung.
Habt ihr eine Ausbildung gemacht?
Ihr könnt auch ein Auslandssemester
in den Lebenslauf schreiben.
Das ist immer gut.
– Also, Deutschkenntnisse.
– Ja! Perfekt. Sehr wichtig!
Schreibt bitte unter
„Sprachkenntnisse“ alle Sprachen
in den Lebenslauf, die ihr gelernt habt.
Computerkenntnisse sind auch wichtig.
Ihr könnt auch eure Hobbys in
den Lebenslauf schreiben,
aber das ist nicht unbedingt nötig.
Wichtig ist nur, dass man sieht,
was ihr gut könnt.
Okay, dann legt mal los.
Ich möchte bis zum Ende der
Stunde eure Lebensläufe sehen.
Und wenn ihr Fragen habt,
dann meldet euch einfach.
„Hallo, Lisa, mein Vater und
ich brauchen deine Hilfe.
Hast du Zeit?“
Ich rufe in einer halben Stunde zurück.